[Music]
Jennifer Lawrence sets the record
straight on Brad Pitt romance rumors on
Thursdays watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen the red Sparrow star was
asked by a caller about rumors that she
dated 54 year old bread no but I've
never like I've met him once in like
2013 so it was very random but I also
wasn't like in a huge hurry to lick
debunk it
although Lawrence admits she had no ties
to the allied actor the 27 year old
actress did dish on her relationship
with her ex-boyfriend Darren Aronofsky
there's not really anybody I can compare
Darren to him there's nobody like him
apparently Amy Schumer helped her cope
with the break-up with this sweet yet
sarcastic gesture when Darren and I
first broke up and I told her and I was
really sad the next day I got a bouquet
of flowers delivered I don't like what
is this
I bring the bouquet flowers and there's
a note and it says I'm so sorry to hear
you're gonna die alone love Amy
and you did laughs right I did
[Music]